lieutenant ray spencer and i'm the
homicide lieutenant with the las vegas
metropolitan police department first off
thank you for showing up here on very
short notice for this press conference
but we thought this was extremely
important after learning some alarming
details on this morning's homicide
that we needed to push the suspect's
photograph out to the public immediately
i will walk you through the details of
what have occurred this morning at
around 30 minutes after midnight
an asian male who appears to be in his
mid-20s was in the area of robindale and
jones when he committed a street robbery
after committing the street robbery he
walked to the gas station at the
intersection that same male walked up to
a vehicle that was parked in the parking
lot
and opened fire into the driver's side
door of the car
that car was unoccupied he then walked
up to another vehicle that was occupied
by a person who was sitting in the car
waiting on his girlfriend who is inside
the store
the suspect
randomly fired multiple rounds into the
driver's side door striking and killing
the victim
the suspect then walked into the gas
station
and noticed there were several customers
in the gas station the suspect fired
multiple rounds down an aisle at a
customer who was standing near a cooler
that customer was able to duck and run
out the store as he was being chased by
the suspect
other customers in the store when this
was occurring were able to flee out a
back door
there was an employee who hid in a
cooler until the incident was over
the suspect stole some items from the
store walked out of the door and was
last seen on foot walking eastbound on
robindale
this appears to be a completely random
incident and i urge every citizen to
please look at this photograph
and see if you recognize him
we desperately need the public's help
and assistance to solve this case and
take a violent person off the street
again he is described as an asian male
appears to be in his mid twenties he is
wearing what appears to be a tactical
vest and a gun belt and he is armed with
a handgun
you can reach out to crime stoppers
there's reward money available and your
information is completely anonymous you
can also call 311 or homicide or you can
email homicide
lvmpd.com so again i'll take a couple
questions if you have them but please i
also want to stress there's a very good
possibility he lives in the area east of
the intersection of robindale and jones
so any viewers who live in that area we
would like to pay special attention
to them again couple questions
he was transported to umc where he was
pronounced deceased how much wars could
could have been
this is could have been extremely worse
this is extremely shocking situation and
that is why we are pushing out the
photograph as quickly as we are
and again with as many rounds that were
fired randomly in the parking lot and in
the grocer or inside the convenience
store
it's a disturbing incident and that is
why we need him captured
because this person has not been caught
in it
well it does appear at this point to be
a random incident from watching the
video in the way the suspect is
dressed and how he is firing into
vehicles one vehicle is unoccupied the
other is occupied and then when he walks
into the store and just starts randomly
shooting
that is why we are here right now
because we are doing everything we can
to get him into custody
i'm not going to get into any
specifics as far as details that were
said at the scene and detailed as far as
the investigation i'll leave it at that
any estimate on how many rounds you
fired uh there was quite a few rounds
that were fired so
a
brief amount of time within a couple
minutes and he was out of the store all
right
we received multiple 911 calls so thank
you guys i appreciate your help